I just need you to stay calm okay yeah
I'm I'm just going to stay angry I find
that relaxes me I will work for you I
will be on you 24/7 I'll be like your
family I'm here when you get here in the
morning sure enough I'll be there
tucking you into bed at night don't
worry it's not gay do we have
questions I think our only question is
uh when can you start right now let's do
it thank you for coming in we will talk
cool I feel good about this I know you
can hit me up on Facebook anytime day or
night you know that right take care
buddy boom so what do you think of your
new
assistant I want to punch you in the
face so bad right now what this is the
one this is oh why do you have so many
keys we did surgery just like you taught
us okay you know what why don't you
girls clean up all this hair and I'm
going to talk to Ron let's cut off our
toes no let's not I'm going to take this
bag too you need to fix this it's not
that bad nobody got hurt it's extremely
bad I love this woman and I just want to
show her that I'm capable of watching
her children without something horrible
happening what did you just say you love
Diane no I did not yes you did that is
so cute for God's sake Hansen will you
please focus on the larger
[Music]
problemy girls girls I don't know what
you think you heard but please don't
tell your mother what you incorrectly
think you heard loves Mommy
I love I love
nothing I can handcraft 17t canoes out
of Western red cedar but I can't glue
two damn gram crackers together there
must be a way out of here I don't think
there is they installed these magnetic
locks 2 years ago there's no way around
them yes there is I'll simply punch my
fist through a window Ron there's
security wire in there you'll slice your
arm open I would rather bleed out than
sit here and talk about my feelings for
10 hours there is another way we'll just
wait a few minutes turn on this Monitor
and then we'll tell Ben that we talked
it out made up I'll just tell them that
I apologized for whatever heroically
caring too much and you admitted that
you're a stubborn Butthead and
everything's fine now why do I have to
be stubborn why can't the problem have
been that I was reasonable and you were
at fault because we want them to believe
us and and not laugh really hard at a
ridiculous science fiction scenario we
are not saying I was the problem if
we're going to lie to them I will not
let you lie to them fine I'll tell them
that for the past three years you've
been a perfect gentleman and scholar and
I am an insane weirdo who despite being
the only reason we even had a friendship
to begin with decided to ruin it out of
the blue for no good
reason that sounds good let's go with
that what are you doing I destroyed the
monitor what if we have an emergency and
have to get up out of here I did not
consider that
possibility Ron I found some
towels you
okay wow apparently Craig is studying
yoga these are the only dry clothes I
could find well you look great I feel
extremely angry so your department
Banned Me from attending games just
because I yell you suck at the Players
according to the complaint you yelled it
at 5-year-old girls who suck
why is that so hard to understand how we
doing pretty good I may have promised a
new Aquatic Center to somebody is that a
problem I diagnosed two melanomas
they're both benign how many more
meetings
20 April was supposed to be the moat
that kept the citizen barbarians away
from Swanson Castle instead she blew up
the castle and stabbed me in the face I
hired you to do one thing
just one I don't care that you text all
day and sleep at your desk in fact I
encourage it but only because you were
doing that one thing keeping this crap
off my
desk give me five minutes before the
next
one okay all public photos of me
recovered name plate removed from my
office door pediatrician files
confiscated
and destroyed anything I'm missing great
news Ron John rafield loves your shirt
what the hell are you talking about oh
I've been taking pictures of you all day
for my new Facebook album Ron Swan
getting off the
grid Tom do you maybe see a problem with
what you've
done I do now yes
sorry
erase erase erase erase all pictures of
Ron erase all pictures of
Ron erase all pictures of Ron what the
hell is happening he accidentally opened
up Vine you just vined your first selfie
Ron and I'm Vining you Vine your selfie
the world is a
nightmare erase all pictures of
Ron erase all pictures of Ron erase all
pictures of
Ron okay here's your scotch okay Jerry
Jerry's here here's your scotch Ron
there we go Ron okay hey you know what
is great Ann's going to take care of you
and an is the best nurse in North
America all right here you
go what you okay did you did you shoot
me what no there was a bird kind of near
me and I know how desperate you were to
prove yourself no no I swear I didn't
Ron I swear to God I've never shot
anyone well you better find out who it
was and then purchase them a coffin
because I'm going to rip them
apart okay okay okay how are you feeling
are you dizzy dizzy are you laded when I
look at my palm I see a lady's mouth
French kissing a dog is that normal is
that normal well the pain medication I
gave you is pretty strong Donnie uses it
for menstral cramps how many did you
take seven eight but I wash them down
with plenty of fluids no Ron you cannot
drink Scotch with this you're going to
need to purge right now okay oh no oh
yeah no I'm not wasting 20 years Scott
can you open his mouth Leslie what open
his mouth no open his mouth okay I'm not
making myself throw it oh Ron I'm sorry
we have to do this this is your own good
bite you open your mouth listen get grab
his mustache open your mouth get
chest open your mouth his
shoulders you know lole the Super Bowl's
in a couple months I usually watch it
with my brothers maybe you could come by
at halftime and shoot me in the
head Ron I'm really sorry that I ruined
your weekend perhaps next time I'm
enjoying some alone time in the men's
restroom you could invite yourself into
my stall and shoot me in the
head look if there's anything I can do
to make it up to how about you shoot me
in the head oh wait you already did
that Ron I have something to say hang on
a minute Tom I'm not done berating
Leslie I am very sorry I I guess I put
too much fuel in the torch oh I don't
know Jerry I think you're being hard on
yourself R are you mad me cuz without
eyebrows I can't really tell it's really
good to see you
Ron you've aged
horribly you son of a didn't oh my
God what is your problem nothing's
changed has it who set the bed on fire
huh I did okay is that what you want to
hear we're fine we're fine take it
easy we need to talk what is that that
this is a flying robot I just shot out
of the sky after it delivered a package
to my house I thought you didn't like to
pass judgment on this the package was
addressed to my son who was 4 years old
and does not own a grizzled do somehow
the robots looked at Diane's computer
and learned something about my child and
then brought him a box of presents so I
destroyed the robot No One Is Safe from
these bastards tell me what to do Leslie
I want to help you take them
down I'm sorry about Andy but I'm not
sorry about what I
did what's my crime I got
bold and a little negligent
nope my office
now hey can I smoke in here you don't
smoke just asking if I can are you high
I'm high on Kaboom don't ask for
permission ask ask for forgiveness
that's right you never did ask me for
permission did you well I'm sorry to
burst your cabubble but I just had my
ass handed to me by the city manager and
now this entire department is C
screwed Ron I'm so so so sorry what the
were you
thinking